Dans "Pourquoi On Dit ?",
je vous raconte cequ'il se cache
derrière les expressions de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous et
surtout, n'oubliez pas la cloche.
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Savez vouspourquoi on dit que
"l'argent n'a pas d'odeur" ?
C'est l'empereur romain Vespasien qui aurait
prononcé ces mots pour la première fois.
Je vous raconte.
Nous sommes en 70 après J.C.
les caisses de Rome sont vides.
Pour les renflouer, Vespasien,
qui vient d'arriver au pouvoir,
décidede mettre en place de nouvelles taxes,
dont une sur l'urine.
À l'époque, celle-ci est
trèsprécieuse.
Elle est collectée dans les toilettes publiques
pour les teinturiers qui l'utilisent
pour dégraisser les laines
et blanchir les tissus.
Car l'urine contient de l'ammoniac.
Évidemment,vu l'origine,
ce nouvel impôt fait jaser,
y compris du côté de Titus,
le fils de Vespasien.
Ce dernier aurait alors fait renifler
à son fils quelques pièces
récoltées grâce a l'urine de ses
concitoyens en déclarant "pecunia non olet",
c'est-à-dire, "l'argent n'a pas d'odeur."
Sous-entendu, cen'est pas parce qu'il vient
de lieux nauséabonds que l'argent a moins de valeur.
L'expressionest toujours utilisée et
sa signification reste la même :
peu importe d'où vient l'argent,
c'est savaleur qui compte.
Le nom de l'empereur Vespasien
a lui aussi franchi les siècles.
Il a inspiré lesurbanistes du 19e siècle.
Dans les années 1830,  les urinoirs publics
installés sur lestrottoirs des grandes villes
sont baptisés "vespasiennes"
en hommage à l'empereur romain.
et"bis repetita" comme on dit,
enfin je crois.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisserun pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands, en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater, abonnez-vous et activer la cloche.